[Applaudissements]
alors être été un petit peu rapidement
mais on ne s'en rend compte alors que
les hommages se sont multipliés 1
puisque c'est l'année de l'anniversaire
de la mort de johnny hallyday bien son
fils david et des attrapés fort il vient
de sortir un nouveau titre qui s'appelle
éternel dans lequel elle dans lequel
pardon il s'en prend clairement à
laëtitia celui qui est vraiment dira le
contraire
je pense qu'il est de mauvaise foi les
paroles sont assez claires regardez on
en parle après
[Musique]
la semaine dernière nous étions trouble
et on se demandait si johnny était
vraiment un homme vient ici on nous
avait menti
on ne veut pas y croire d'autant plus
que cette semaine ces jours de deuil
national
nous sommes le 5 décembre et on voulait
aussi vous parler de 1er décembre 2007
le monde se préparent à l'hommage qui
lui sera rendu ce dimanche à l'église de
la madeleine
dorénavant véritable mausolée du
chanteur mais déjà avant-hier en pleine
nuit décalage horaire oblige laeticia
jade et joy et des centaines de fans
honorait la mémoire du chanteur sur sa
tombe à saint barth
[Musique]
tiens il ne manque personne le rat smet
et david hallyday ne communiquez pas et
pour cause david sortait son nouveau
clip éternel reproche à peine déguisée à
l'égard de laëtitia
on sa main on peut souffler la flamme du
même si david prend quelques pensées d
une précaution juridique vous adresser
dans cette chanson c'est mon expérience
raconte l'expérience de ce que j'ai vécu
à vous de voir un mystère qui n'a pas
tenu bien longtemps puisque david est on
ne peut plus explicite dans un quotidien
national
[Musique]
jusqu'à la pierre tombale je vais
attaquer laetitia en frontal
bonne ou mauvaise idée
l'amour est 7e voilà david hallyday qui
a taclé fiscale chez toi tu sais l'udc
avait rien dit pendant un an maintenant
liban depuis sept à huit ça ça balance
pas mal à leurs attaques et laeticia
hallyday et dans une chanson on pas
reprendre les paroles mais c'est très
très clair un tu peux m'empêcher de
poser ma main sur son corps blessé tu
peux m'empêcher de tenir ça m'a rien ne
peut souffler la flamme du jeu vient
c'est que comme ça dans une interview on
lui a dit est ce que c'est une attaque l
été c répond non ouais c'est l'anglais
magali ça veut dire non pas du tout et
pourtant ça paraît assez clair donc pour
vous attaquer ou pas laetitia
frontalement bonne idée sébastien
pourquoi oui c'est une bonne idée parce
qu'il ne le fait pas frontalement il le
fait à travers une chanson dont il
s'exprime pas ce que lui
la musique c'est sa façon de s'exprimer
on sent que l'histoire de la halle est
saluée rester vraiment en travers
il n'avait pas parlé pendant un an je
pense qu'il était temps de le faire et
la façon de le faire me semble plus
judicieuse que que d'aller au journal de
tf1
très bien luc bonne idée aussi c'est
tout à fait ça c'est une très bonne idée
de l'aide les deux chansons qui sont
sortis avait deux singles y en a un pour
dire cette lettre qui n'a pas pu donner
à son père l'autre c'est pour dire qu'il
n'a pas pu voir son père les derniers
jours et pas le rencontrer et yaren plus
forte de le dire comme ça en chansons de
le dire avec émotion et parce que du
coup c'est fait d'une manière noble
entre guillemets parce que c'est pas
c'est pas des bêtes d'attaquer un peu
étonné aussi que j'admire un palan
baboni d'être pas ça il peut un peu
hypocrite vous donc de faire une maj
trouve que c'est une bonne idée parce
que du coup c'est en plein dans la promo
de son disque donc ça c'est tout bénef
et en plus de ça les gens ils et les a
tous ramené à sa cause ne soit plein de
courriers ou les gens disent voyait
david il n'a pas pu voir son père avant
de mourir c'est dégueulasse à tata en
fin de vie qu'il a fait ça franchement
y'a plus qu'à est-ce que c'était myriam
de son côté parce que c'est vrai mais on
me dit que laeticia johnny au
presse-purée ça cartonne quand c'est
david ça ça marche moins est vrai ça
marche moi ou quoi
c'est vraiment en fait ce qui marche
moins gens il touche moins les gens
c'est aussi un homme en général les
hommes c'est de la presse féminine ça
touche un peu moins et puis ce qui
marche vraiment c'est laetitia versus
l'aura très bien là ça cartonne du tout
mauvaise idée
pourquoi mauvaise idée de s'en prendre à
laetitia et en chanson c'est plutôt joli
je pensais vous seriez pour vous parce
que non parce que je pense qu'il faut
que ça s'arrête tout ça là c'est glauque
cette guerre c'était tout le monde
toutes ces torrents de boue ça il ya une
phrase c'est un peu vulgaire pardon
quand on remue la merde on sent la merde
et là c'est ben on en a eu six mandats
et les chansons ça c'est c'est moi j'ai
envie que ça s'arrête et médium la scène
que j'ai passé un peu démago ce que vous
dites mais c'est comme si vous étiez
vous qu'elle s'arrête bah oui c'est pas
ça oui bien sûr ces médiums mais mais la
faille pour katherine tweedie parce que
c'est quand même quelque chose qui passe
c'est une affaire qui passionne les gens
tout le monde dit il faut que ça
s'arrête et ça rebondit mais chapeau les
magazines
alors oui mais ça ça me ressemble pas ce
mois ci le problème que j'ai sa mort
écrit un bouquin en travaux depuis tout
à l'heure on voit des photos de david
hallyday avec le t-shirt du groupe joy
division qu'un des plus grands groupes
de rock anglais de tous les temps il
fait un album de variétés inodore avec
ces chansons là qui ne lui ressemble pas
c'est tout proche de david cd qu'il veut
faire quelque chose qui me ressemble ma
personne n'en parle ça marche pas il
fait des trucs de rock en anglais jouent
la batterie et pour attirer l'attention
du grand public ils obligés de faire des
chansons avec des ficelles derrière 11
cents moi je pense que dans deux ans il
va nous dire j'aurais pas dû qu'à stage
était maladroit j'ai essayé de récupérer
vous écrire un bouquin
moi je trouve touchant rapidement magali
% c'est quand même ça et ça a été la
chanson de la réconciliation fait en
tout cas pas de news viallon d'entre 100
% et femmes un homme qu'il a écrit pour
son père et son père c'est comporte avec
louis est exactement de la même manière
elle s'était comporté qu'un autre auteur
compositeur ça ne les a jamais rapproché
ben on rentre là les gens bananière et
entendu mes rides le dire hier alors
bannie compte année c'est que c'est
jamais très clair il étalait sept à huit
il n'emploie pas de nom il part il
accuse personnes il dit easy mais il dit
pas trop dans la chanson il dit mais il
dit pas trop alors qu'elle est allée au
journal de 20 heures elle a parlé elle a
dit les choses donc dit les choses ou
dit rien
le mot de la fin pour rachel rachel ça
vous touche tout ça moi ça me touche
après comme toutes les histoires de
famille voilà c'est compliqué mais moi
je trouve ça bien qu'il ait créé deux
chansons osées vous êtes aux pros
david laura ou plutôt pro laetitia moi
je dirais david et elora bienvenue
camarades